عده الى تطورات في الضفه الغربيه معنا من
طول كرم مراسل الجزيره ليث جعار ليث اخر
التطورات المرتبطه بالاقتحام الاسرائيليه
لمناطق في الضفه الغربيه تحديدا مخيمي طول
كرم ونور
شمس نعم العمليه العسكريه لا تزال متواصله
حتى هذه اللحظه في مخيم طول كرم بعد ما
يزيد او ما يقارب ال 40 ساعه على بدء هذه
العمليه العس عريه جيش الاحتلال متواصل في
عملياته في داخل المخيم تحديدا اقتحامات
المنازل وتدمير البنى التحتيه بيان جيش
الاحتلال تحدث عن ثمانيه شهداء خلال
العمليه العسكريه والتي لا تزال حتى هذه
اللحظه متواصله هنا نرصد اليات الاحتلال
العسكريه التي لا تزال تدفع او يدفع الجيش
بها نحو مخيم طول كرم ل ساعات طويله حتى
هذه اللحظه خلال او بيان الجيش الذي تحدث
عن ثمانيه شهداء سته منهم اعلنت عنهم
وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه فيما هناك شهيد
سابع تم اخذه ومصادره جثمانه امس خلال
اقتحام الاحتلال وبدايه هذا الاقتحام
وهناك شهيد ثامن حتى هذه اللحظه لا يزال
داخل المخيم يمنع الاحتلال طواقم الاسعاف
من الوصول اليه قبل اقل من نصف ساعه قام
جنود الاحتلال بربط رجليه بحبل طويل ومن
ثم سحبه جرا من داخل الازقه ايه
وهو واطلق وحيث اطلق الاحتلال النار عليه
خلال اليوم ايه من قبل القناصه ما ادى الى
وقوعه على الارض اكثر من خمسه ساعات على
الارض ايه منع الاحتلال طواقم الاسعاف
وطواقم الهلال الاحمر من الوصول اليه او
نقله ايه رفضا من قبل الاحتلال قبل قليل
كما اسلفنا قوات الاحتلال قامت بسحبه وجره
في ساحه المخيم بعد ربطه من رجليه بحسب
شهود العيان المتواجدين في تلك المنطقه
اكثر من 15 اصابه بعضها اصيب بالرصاص الحي
البعض الاخر اصيب نتيجه للضرب او هناك
تحديدا اربعه اصابات نتيجه للضرب المبرح
من قبل الاحتلال ما تم اعتقاله مجمل ما تم
اعتقاله حتى هذه اللحظه اكثر من 100
فلسطيني بعضهم لا يزال يخضع لتحقيق رسميا
تم تحويل الى مراكز التحقيق في الداخل 15
فلسطينيا فيما لا يزال يخضع البعض الاخر
منهم في مراكز التحقيق حقيقه مخيم طول كرم
منذ ساعات طويله منفصل عن الكل الفلسطيني
محاصر من كافه المحاور ايه ايه بحسب
حقوقيون يؤكدون ان المخيم بات ايه منطقه
يعني مدمره بالكامل او منطقه منكوبه نتيجه
لمنع الدواء منع الطعام منع خروج ودخول
المواطنين من خارج وداخل هذا المخيم
العمليه العسكريه متواصله والتدمير متواصل
جدران المنازل التخريب وا عدد كبير من
المواطنين حقيقه منعوا من التواصل مع
الخارج لا يوجد اي معلومات واضحه عن
مصيرهم هنا ايضا نرصد من جديد تحرك
للاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه في المنطقه
حيث تحاول الاليات العسكريه اعمال او تقوم
باعمال الاستفزاز في طرق مدينه طول كرم
وصولا الى حاجز 104 الذي يفرض يفرض عليه
الاحتلال او يخرج منه الاحتلال باتجاه
مدينه طول كرم
وايضا المخيمات خلال هذه العمليه العسكريه
نفذ الاحتلال عمليه عسكريه وتدمير للبنى
التحتيه في مخيم نور شمس حيث
من الم لا يسمعنا مس الجزيره لجع كنت معنا
من مخيم طول كرم شكرا لك